Hola Muy Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
Franz 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña Alejandra freshner actriz
argentina con una enorme trayectoria en
cine en teatro entre televisión desde
los años 80 es una de las protagonistas
de la película argentina 1985 el film
que desde el año 2022 sacude a
espectadores a lo largo de todo el mundo
y que va a competir en los premios Oscar
como mejor película extranjera les
Contamos a nuestra audiencia
internacional que esta película retoma
La historia de los juicios a las juntas
militares que dirigieron la última
dictadura Cívico militar en Argentina un
hecho que marcó la historia de este país
como la única nación en toda la historia
universal en la que un tribunal civil
condenó a una dictadura militar la
historia sigue entre otros aspectos de
todo este proceso Las investigaciones
realizadas por los fiscales Julio es
trasera y Luis Moreno Ocampo Alejandra
fresner interpreta a la esposa y
compañera de vida destracera Alejandra
felicitaciones Argentina 1985 llega a
los Oscar y con una historia que
atraviesa absolutamente a la Argentina
que hace parte de uno de los episodios
que marcaron al país Cómo estás Cómo
recibiste esta noticia cómo te sentís
Ah estamos ahí manejea manija manija me
siento vale con una alegría Total como
son muchas emociones esta película nos
nos viene dando muchas emociones desde
su estreno en el festival de Venecia que
se veía al público por primera vez Yo
tuve la fortuna de estar en ese lugar y
lo que vivimos esa noche fue algo
inolvidable Porque además vimos por
primera vez la película con público
Entonces ahora Bueno uno ya sabe que la
gente le encanta lo que la película es
sucede lo que sucede pero esa primera
vez fue como muy alucinante y todo el
recorrido de la película internacional
fue muy alucinante muy loco a veces
pensar que un hecho de si bien es una
ficción pero es sobre nuestra historia
sobre un momento muy importante de
nuestra historia
no te imaginas que en otros lugares
pueda tener ese esa resonancia creo que
la película
La tiene muy fuerte primero porque
dialoga muy fuerte con el presente un
mundo eso violento digo que rompe pactos
democráticos que quiere golpes de estado
o discursos de odio y hoy la película
nos viene como a recordar no y a muchas
cosas a poner en valor muchísimas
cuestiones segundo que las personas
jóvenes las propias de nuestro país las
chicas nos pida los pibes de quince años
les pregunten a sus padres y vos qué
dónde estabas en el cuando fueron los
juiches a las juntas tenías diez años
sabías lo que estaba pasando
esa conversación que se dio en Argentina
no solo a nivel internacional sino
dentro de nuestro propio país la
película fue un acontecimiento social y
eso es es mucho más de lo que la
película puede aspirar
diez horas disculpa si es por no por
favor Alejandro si es una alegría
absoluta para vos para Argentina
hablabas recién de aquel estreno en
Venecia no hubo una ovación de unos 9
minutos por lo menos no larguísimo una
emoción una locura Y bueno la misma
emoción que se veía por supuesto en los
cines argentinos yo no la pude versiones
argentinos pero me trasladaron
muchísimas experiencias gente desde allá
O sea que la película es una historia
Argentina pero conmueve también en el
exterior digo toca fibras de otras
historias qué crees que ocurre ahí
yo creo que ocurre ocurre lo que ocurre
por ejemplo te digo no sé vos vas a
España y los españoles
digo un juicio civil a un tribunal
militar es algo que no existe en el
mundo Ya de por sí creo que somos el
único país que que hizo un movimiento de
de tamaño Calibre
[Música]
vos vas a España y tienen a los digo te
dicen nosotros envidiamos lo que ustedes
hicieron Claro en vuestro país porque
nosotros tenemos los muertos los
desaparecidos de la dictadura de Franco
en en las rutas enterrados no sabemos ni
Quiénes son ni dónde están y Y
entonces
hay algo ahí Perdón que te interrumpa no
como algo ahí del orden de hacer
justicia no ante el mal una justicia que
muchísimos países no tuvieron
exactamente entonces creo que es por un
lado esta esta justicia frente a poderes
que siempre son poderes represivos
poderes que toman las los poderes por
las armas digamos poderes que con las
que contra los que es muy complejo
revelarse poderes que digamos y aquí y
este digamos cuando el poder Toma por
las armas un estado se llama terrorismo
de estado tiene un nombre y
terrorismo de estado sea juzgado y
castigado es es un signo de que la
impunidad No no es algo deseable y que
todo lo contrario este
hay hay cosas a las que les decimos
nunca más y hay cosas digamos y el hecho
de poder haberlo hecho desde desde un
desde el poder democrático es como que
nos legitima como sociedad a
a saber que hay cosas que no que no las
queremos que no tienen que volver a
suceder
que a veces pensamos que ya pasaron una
vez y no van a volver a pasar y de
pronto vivimos en un mundo donde la
rueda vuelve y vemos esto digo un mundo
de discurso de odio un mundo de
violencia un mundo de armas un mundo que
no que quiere romper los pactos
democráticos
y bueno Me parece que en ese sentido
también siento que la película tiene
casi una utilidad No aquí en nuestro
país de pronto y siento que cuando un
objeto artístico un objeto
cinematográfico
pasa ese otro estadio digamos de pasar
de ser un objeto artístico hacer un
objeto social que tiene una utilidad
para la educación para las me parece que
es eso algo ya desde otro orden
proveedor de vehículo para transmitir
muchísimas cosas exactamente
absolutamente Y eso es muy alucinante
muy
agradezco mucho esta vida que tengo
desde que me da la posibilidad de de
vivir esto y el orgullo con que lo vivo
porque
de verdad siento un gran orgullo cuando
hicimos la película cuando leí el guión
nunca imaginamos nadie que todas estas
cosas nos iban a pasar
y ya sentir que en nuestro país al menos
la película es de todas y de todos O sea
que vos sentís que que la película no es
tuya a nivel director ni de los actores
ni de los rubros técnicos ni de la
vestuarista ni de la directora de arte
ni del cámara ni de los eléctricos sino
que la película es de los argentinos del
mundo te diría esto es un montón digo es
algo es algo
ahora hablabas no de esa como también
utilidad no de esta película Como
vehículo para muchas otras cosas y uno
cuando la ve sobre todo bueno siendo
argentinos especialmente no hay una hay
una cercanía que es inevitable no la
piel de gallina Escuchar El alegato de
extracera no los el discurso de Adriana
No Adriana calvo que tantas veces hemos
escuchado a lo largo de nuestras vidas
que bueno mientras te estoy haciendo la
pregunta se me eriza la piel Alejandra
pero en esto de hablar de la película
Como un vehículo para otras cosas no
como cierta utilidad no solo
históricamente pero le queda a uno la
sensación de que esto tiene que estar en
los Colegios Alejandra para que no se
diluya la lucha para que la lucha por la
verdad la memoria y la justicia siga
porque vos bien decías nada está
garantizado de hecho Bueno en la
película no está pero años posteriores
en los 90 vinieron las leyes de
impunidad
exactamente si uno mira la línea digamos
la línea de la historia
hace como
eso después vinieron la impunidad del
punto final
pero bueno Luego se recuperaron creo que
la película Tiene un gran presente
también porque hoy al día de hoy siguen
los juicios claro profesores en
Argentina hay juicios se llevan adelante
los juicios siguen habiendo testimonios
y se siguen encarcelando asesinos y
represores entonces
Esto no es algo terminado que sucedió
Esto es algo que tiene una continuidad y
aquí por ejemplo hay una provincia que
es Mendoza donde el senador decidió o
normativizó que la película entrara en
la currícula del colegio secundario la
vuelta a la democracia y eso para mí
está buenísimo Oscar pero digo eso me
parece un nivel de Premio alto la verdad
sentir que de pronto haces una película
y que esa película puede ser parte del
de la formación de y además en forma de
película porque Bueno uno puede estudiar
y si te toca una buena profesora de
historia buenísimo que te toca Una profe
o un profe medio plomo sí o incluso
negacionista o que reproduzca discursos
geológicamente digamos exactamente digo
creo que también Además eso digo que que
que nuestra digamos que que que que que
pensemos que esta es una una película
que que nos puede educar de algún modo
Aunque es un montón lo que digo y no no
lo digo modo pretenciosa lo absoluto Me
parece que que es un montón es es un
montón de cosas buenas
De verdad este para para nosotras y
porque a veces creo que la película
tiene como unos méritos cinematográficos
enormes No no es solamente un vehículo
de transmitir como nuestra historia sino
que tiene digamos lo hace de un modo
cinematográficamente tan artístico que
también logra que esa historia funcione
Sí incluso Perdón que te interrumpa pero
visualmente es un viaje a los 80
zarpado el viaje a los 80 que te comes Y
vos viviste los 80 como los suena una
muchacha muy jovencita cuando fueron los
juicios los vivís en una muchacha joven
y fui a la escuela secundaria en
dictadura O sea que para mí digamos era
esta película y ahora representarla es
como un orgullo triple cuádruple
infinito porque siento que que mi cuerpo
está con digamos tiene esa historia
tatuada en mi sangre ni en mis neuronas
y en
vísceras entonces
digo haber vivido esa época y poder
contarla Bueno es es también algo que
para mí tiene como un condimento que me
me hace
enorgullecerme muchísimo más este
sí sí Igual me perdí que estaba diciendo
estamos llegando al final podría seguir
horas Charlando contigo y más en un día
como hoy te agradezco muchísimo Te
felicito en una vez más y haciendo
fuerza desde acá para que en marzo No si
bien Tengo entendido será la entrega de
los premios sí hacemos fuerza le ponemos
le ponemos todo vamos con
América Latina hinchando por Argentina
1985 Alejandra Muchísimas gracias una
vez más y felicitaciones de nuevo
gracias a vos y abrazo para todos así a
vos una vez más a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a que sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
France 24 no dejen de acompañarnos sigan
con nosotros
[Música]